Miami Dolphins defensive tackle Kendrick  Norton is in the hospital this morning  after suffering serious injuries in a  car crash yesterday police say the 22  year old was driving his truck near  Miami when he crashed into a concrete  barrier and overturned norton's agent  confirms his arm was amputated his  injuries are not considered to be  life-threatening  Norton's girlfriend was also in the car  at the time she suffered minor injuries  a family friend tells the Miami Herald  that Norton's vehicle was cut off by  another car just before the crash the  Miami Dolphins said in a statement our  thoughts and prayers are with Kendrick  and his family during this time